[Music]
since the time of Homer ancient stories
told of fierce warriors dwelling beyond
the Mediterranean world striking fear
into the mightiest empires of antiquity
their exploits were recounted by many
epic poets they fought in the legendary
Trojan War and their grand army invaded
Athens jason and the argonauts passed by
their shores fairly avoiding their
deadly arrows these formidable fighters
faced off against the greatest champions
of myth Heracles Theseus and Achilles
and every single one of these warriors
was a woman the war loving Amazon's
quote unquote the equals of men
encouraged and skill were familiar to
everyone in ancient Greece Amazon battle
scenes decorated the Parthenon on the
Athenian Acropolis paintings and statues
of Amazon's adorned temples and public
spaces little girls played with Amazon
dolls and Amazon's were a favorite
subject on Greek vase paintings in Greek
art and literature they were depicted as
daring and desirable but also terrifying
and deadly and doomed to die at the
hands of Greek heroes were Amazon's
merely figures of myth or something more
it was long assumed that they were
imaginary like the Cyclops and centaurs
but curiously enough stories from
ancient Egypt Persia the Middle East
Central Asia India and China also
featured Amazon like warrior women and
Amazon's were described in ancient
historical accounts not just myths
writers like Herodotus Plato and Strabo
never doubted their existence so who
were the real women warriors known as
Amazon's ancient historians located the
Amazon homeland in Sofia the vast
territory stretching from the Black Sea
across the steppes of Central Asia this
immense region was populated by nomadic
tribes whose lives centered on horses
archery and warfare their culture
flourished for about 1,000
years beginning around 800 BC feared by
Greeks Persians and the Chinese the Sith
Ian's left no written records but we can
find clues in how their neighbors
describe to them as well as in
archaeology Citians ancestors were the
first to ride horses and they invented
the recurve bow and because a female
mounted Archer could be as fast and as
deadly as a male all children were
trained to ride and shoot women hunted
and fought alongside men using the same
weapons the harsh landscape and their
nomadic lifestyle created its own form
of equality this amazed the ancient
Greeks whose women led restricted indoor
lives
the earliest stories of the Sith ian's
and Amazon's may have been exaggerated
rumors but as the Greeks began to trade
around the Black Sea and further east
their portrayals became more realistic
early depictions of Amazon's showed them
with Greek weapons and armor but in
later representations they wielded bows
and battle axes rode horses and wore
pointed caps and patterned trousers
characteristic of steppe nomads until
recently no one was sure how strong the
links were between Scythian and the
Amazons of Greek myth but recent
archaeological discoveries have provided
ample evidence more than a thousand
ancient Scythian kurgans or burial
mounds have been excavated containing
skeletons and weapons archaeologists had
previously assumed that weapons could
only belong to male warriors but modern
DNA analysis so far has revealed that
about 300 skeletons buried with weapons
belong to females ranging in age from 10
to 45 and more are being found every
year the women's skeletons show battle
injuries ribs slashed by swords skulls
bashed by battle axes and arrows
embedded in bones in classical art and
writings the fearsome Amazons were
always portrayed
as brave and heroic in male-dominated
classical Greece however
the very idea of strong women who glory
in freedom and war aroused mixed
feelings and yet the Greeks were also
drawn to Galit Aryan ideals is it
possible that the mythic realm of
thrilling Amazon tales was a way to
imagine women and men as equal
companions if you agree that
well-behaved women seldom make history
check out this playlist to meet a few of
our favorite troublemakers
[Music]
you